hi there steve kaufman
today i'm going to try to be a little
controversial
i am sure that i will generate a lot
more thumbs down than i have in the past
i'm going to talk about linguistics and
language learning and the reason is that
i discovered uh through the internet
a person called amore gaethan i'm not
sure how his name is pronounced but it's
someone who taught
english as a foreign language for 35
years in britain
i have put on my blog
a link to an article he wrote about
rational language teaching and i'm also
going to put a link at my blog to an
article he wrote called
anti-linguistics or something to that
effect
uh it's also a book that he published
and he is a very
clear thinker and who debunks
a lot of the um unnecessary complication
that surrounds the field of linguistics
and language teaching how relevant do i
feel linguistics is to language learning
answer not very
not very
all these terms like morphology and
phonemes and syntax
don't add much
to our knowledge of
language learning
uh all of the considerable research
that's been done
in various linguistics departments on
and particularly in so far as applied
linguistics is concerned
into language learning hasn't done much
to improve the quality of language
instruction
uh there are fads as gaethan
points out
uh different fads in language
instruction different fads in
linguistics
and the fallacy as he points out is this
attempt to come up with
codes or
systems or theories
to describe what is in fact much simpler
and more natural and that is how we use
language
uh you know a primary example of this
unnecessary
complication is the famous chomsky
theory of universal grammar
which is one of the mainstays one of the
sort of canons of linguistics
some people see him as akin to darwin
in terms of his discovery
according to him a discovery that we
have some
innate
uh
sort of capability
to learn languages
that our ability to learn languages is
not just based on the way the brain
learns other things in other words how
the brain develops patterns
to deal with all of the experiences that
it encounters in life
his position is that
based on his theory of uh
limited stimulus or paucity of stimulus
p-a-u-c-i-t-y i think it is
that there isn't enough stimulus simply
from
our exposure as
children to the language to explain the
fact that within a few years a child is
able to speak grammatically correctly
his position is that there must be some
innate
ability to
sort of understand or identify what is
correct grammar and what is not correct
grammar and since grammars vary from
language to language there must be a
universal grammar sort of the essence of
grammar that is
hardwired in our brains
and that that is then the secret of why
we are able to understand
what is correct and not correct
i just i'm not a i have never studied
linguistics i've read up on it i i just
can't see how this makes sense
i've studied 14 languages
every language is different the grammar
is different
and what is difficult in learning a
language
to my mind would not be this sort of
essence of grammar
but all the ways in which different
languages are different
all of the exceptions
all of the
you know idiomatic patterns the
vocabulary that's a huge part of
learning a language and there's no way
that a child is born with some innate
universal vocabulary for all the
different languages
and and but even in terms of grammar
like
i don't know in russian you say
you you they talk for example when you
read pinker and chomsky they talk about
uh you know if a language has this then
it has that or
we know instinctively that certain word
word order is not correct but word order
varies all over the place and again in
the case of russian you can actually
vary you can say to say
you know
you have a book you say book your book
to you is book
book is to you you can move it around in
different ways that would not make sense
in english and all of the examples that
i see in in the examples that pinker and
chomsky use seem to relate to english
at any rate
gaithen points out that some of these if
the language has x therefore y are quite
incorrect that finnish doesn't conform
to it uh
pinker had some examples of how you flip
the order for questions well in japanese
you say you know hondes hondesca that's
a question you don't flip anything and
for that matter
uh you know in japanese uh you know if
in russian if you say uh
um
i have a book
in japanese you say hong aru
book is or book r it doesn't even
specify whether it's is or are i mean
there are so many varieties and and when
you read a russian grammar book the
complexity like uh you know one of
something in god one year that's the
nominative singular advantage
that's the genitive singular of the word
for year
but then five or more
is uh
which is the
genitive plural of the word for summer
okay now
i'm sure the chomsky
supporters will say that those
variations don't really matter but it's
the variations that are difficult the
variations that are so tremendously
complex any supposed
um universal essence of grammar would be
child's play compared to the complexity
of learning all of these other
exceptions and vocabulary and idioms and
so forth and so on and if a child can
learn all those other things in the
first few years of his or her life just
by listening and and reacting to
what the child hears uh getting it wrong
a few times and then eventually getting
it right
that to me is the bigger job and and i
think that job is not so very different
from what we do as adults when we learn
except that as adults we have some
psycho psychological hang-ups uh because
we're afraid to make mistakes and we
also have the advantage of having more
more vocabulary so
uh but even in general uh you know
linguistics uh yeah on the other hand
yeah
uh
what was i gonna say you know you go to
the internet
and
the problem with linguistics to me is
in many cases people who teach languages
have been studying linguistics so
they're all wrapped up in these theories
uh
and um so if i google for example esl
and critical thinking i find like
millions of pages because i know this
from experience having been on this
esl teachers forum on the internet they
love to get into critical thinking
because they somehow feel that they can
teach someone who's not a native speaker
of english critical thinking not to me
obvious at all that they're better at
critical thinking it is also not obvious
to me that critical thinking is related
to language learning uh as my favor one
of my favorite educators ruben alves
whom i listened to a lot when i was
learning portuguese says that when we
are reading
nothing destroys our interest in reading
as much as being asked to analyze what
we have read to answer questions about
what we have read
so
again i believe that all of this over
complication is actually it discourages
language learning
all of the terminology about morphemes
and phonemes and syntax and so forth
discourages language learning
all of the
fads
in the classrooms role-playing getting
uh students who speak the language
imperfectly to speak to each other
is not effective as gaithan again points
out far better that they listen to
the is spoken by a native speaker and so
ultimately
and and i should point out as well that
uh
as gaitham points out you know what
happens in linguistics i think uh humans
like a theory a system uh
and so then you get the sort of high
priests of these system uh you know
marx's uh
uh you know uh
theory of history which is complete bunk
but
uh and of course it didn't turn out to
be correct is his
whatever his theory was called
historical materialism or whatever it
was
stages of of different societies and so
forth and yet there are people who
firmly believe who who analyze all the
uh events of history and so forth uh
through the prism of this uh marxist
approach to history it's like the the
thought that the sun revolves around the
earth and we had the high priests of
that uh
and uh
yeah so linguistics is one of those
relatively
uninteresting to most people relatively
impractical
but it has that same appeal that marxism
or any other theory has
dogma it's sort of intellectually
challenging and so people create
theories and counter theories and so
forth unlike darwin
uh
the universal grammar theory
is not based on observation it's based
on making an assumption
that languages are too complicated to
learn based on the limited exposure that
the children get therefore there must be
a universal grammar but it's not based
on anything that is provable or
observable
so and why is this important because i
think the essence of language learning
is its simplicity in other words
we need we don't have any universal
grammar in our heads as second language
learners were very much influenced by
our first language which limits you know
we expect the sounds the structures and
so forth to conform to what we learned
for our first language which is kind of
hardwired in our brain and we need to
expose our brains to as much as possible
of the second language so that the brain
has a chance to develop
another set of patterns to deal with the
second language and the more open-minded
we are the more we want to again
attitude the more we like it so because
the our ability to learn is influenced
by emotion this is another thing that
gaitham points points out that all of
these studies of whether
language system learning system a is
better than language learning system b
hasn't the ability to evaluate
the emotional commitment of the learner
and therefore a lot of the results are
not that useful
uh however however
you know i'll take an example of the
there was a study by the american uh
center for applied linguistics on the
effectiveness of classmates
classroom instructional hours
on esl learning english learning by
immigrants and they showed that it you
know it improved depending on the number
of hours but in fact in some cases it
went down
the more instructional hours the poorer
the results
uh
and why is that because maybe the
instructional hours are quite irrelevant
what matters more
is the emotional commitment of the
learners the extent to which they do
things outside the classroom do they
read on their own do they listen on
their own are they working are they
working in an english-speaking
environment these are much more
important than the instructional hours
yet most studies on language learning
deal with what happens in the classroom
it's possible that the classroom is the
least important factor in terms of
language learning uh success again we
had this example in canada of of several
thousand chinese immigrants who were
measured after seven years and who had
essentially made no progress in their
language learning despite attending
language class so
to me as i often say you know obviously
it's attitude number one time with the
language and then developing this
ability to notice
and massive input read listen then
eventually speak
write
these are simple you don't need to know
terms like morpheme phoneme syntax or
anything else you don't need to know
about linguistics
all you need to do is to be motivated to
learn the language and ingest
read listen as much of it as you can and
then start speaking about
using the language and don't worry about
how you sound and don't worry about all
this other stuff so i'm sure that will
generate a lot of thumbs down i'm
looking forward to your comments bye for
now